As you may have guessed, the right choice is
no. The operating system should not be taking precious
resources away from an application. For example, if I'm
running a program such as, computing the prime number up
to a billion, it's going to need a lot of
resources, CPU cycles in particular, and during that time
I don't want the operating system stealing cycles away
from me. So operating system is also a program and
has to run on the CPU as we saw when we talked about how an operating
system deals with external interrupts. So it is going to need some resources,
CPU and memory cycles, to do it's work. But a good operating system will take
the minimal amount of time and minimal amount of resources to do it's thing.
So the right answer is no, as otherwise you will not use an operating system.
It's sort of like when give to a charity.
The first question you ask is, what percentage
of the collection is used by the charity
as administrative overhead? You don't want to give to
a charity that spends more than a few
percentage points of the collections on administrative overhead.
Same thing with an operating system. Most of the time, the
resources, CPU, memory and so on, is being used for running the
applications. The operating system gets in the way as a broker, only
for arbitrating and providing the resources needed by
an application safely and securely, and then get's out of the way
as quickly as possible. So the right answer is no.